[Music]
here the writer got the matching buzz
cut I'm actually no I copied Ryder Ryder
right away my provider Lee buzzing his
hand for a long time yeah no this was
this was just a you know I that was just
a part of the part that I was playing
right so Ryder I was more riders like
but when I did it we both he was like oh
my god we actually it was the first time
he could see the Penguins that we looked
at that you know he looked like his
mommy but it was it was really cool now
it's all starting to grow out you know
Ryder's growing his client's got mines
already how are you enjoying life with a
buzz cut because you're you're long
blonde hair was so iconic like you think
hey Hudson it's that you know almost
famous like long blonde hair so how are
you enjoying when you completely you
know well I like the ease of it you know
what I mean I don't know I think the
only people that put I mean obviously
when I when I first did it it was like
oh how's this gonna feel but I do know
that an actor no because I think that
when you choose to be an actor you
choose to be an actor to play roles that
mean that you shift things
there's no preciousness to like what
other people would see is something that
they identify with you as when you're an
actor you sort of one identify with
different character these different
roles you can get caught up in the fact
that oh no what happens if the identity
that people will see me as is like god I
just don't care I just don't think about
so yeah like that so for me I was just
excited to get rid of all the old yeah
Harris yeah and then when I looked at
the hair when I came off I was like you
know
I'm so happy this is gone it was really
yes you see what a where a tear
[Music]
you